Jeff Darlington the Peripatetic ESPN NFL
reporter he's appeared on the ESPN NFL
shows SportsCenter get up and more in
fact he had a big get up appearance and
that brought some headlines where he was
talking about Tom Brady and would be
surprised if Tom Brady went back to New
England Jeff what was the reaction to
that report it was I think that people
Dan are still sort of suspended in this
area where they just don't think it's
going to happen where they think he will
definitely go back to New England based
on I think at this point nothing but the
idea that we've seen this for twenty
years and why should we expect any
different I think that's understandable
but it's not necessarily accurate but
explain is this a vibe you're hearing or
was it a like you know I know I know
it's definitely not for seems like I
just like reporters talking to other
reporters like that's not how I operate
I'm not at the combine I go to combine
mostly but I'm not there it's not you
know it's been covering Lee for 15 years
we're pretty dialed into the heat world
and all things there and has my contact
within that world and so so certainly
when I'm saying something I'm not saying
it light-hearted nor am I saying it as a
rumor that I heard I bought at the
combine yeah that was what was confusing
Jeff because you're your reporter you're
journalists in it and it felt like it
was more of just a hey I'm on the show
with greenie and get up and they want
hot takes and hey I'm hearing this and
that's where I just didn't know how deep
that report was that might have been
just the way you interpreted it I don't
think um which is fine I mean I
understand that's that's part of the
deal
like for instance you know I didn't say
I maybe I didn't use more sources enough
I don't know if that's like the hot
trigger word that people need to hear
but but like I don't know did you catch
the hole did you catch the segment where
I talked about
kind of context behind it the people
close to him kind of talked to him and
he says he's the one who tells them like
to not expect him to go back whereas
those people are kind of like the other
we still think like Tom will go in that
office with Bill Belichick if you'll
still find a way to convince you know
Tom to stick around we we don't follow
context here Jeff that shifty but I
can't watch get up while I'm getting up
on my own show blame chef teah that was
poor reporting on chef T's part you're
the one who said when chef D says you
believe it you said when Glazer says you
believe it say something that doesn't
fit into what people want to believe
they're going to go the other way and
like I'll be honest I got it sounds
really yeah what can you say like it
sounds lame for me to be like I talked
to all of the people who know I'm trying
to walk this might not sound like the
tool people understand I'm plugged in so
like I get it but I'm also kind of like
god I don't know I'm actually a pretty
like reasoned I'd like to say I have a
decent reputation of being accurate with
my reporting but I understand when it's
something like this it just takes on
this life it reminds me actually of like
the Tim Tebow year in 2011 where
everything just takes on a life of its
own and that's fair I understand that I
think throwing in sources because
there's you make fun of that as well no
no not with you I mean there's certain
guys I wouldn't if you said hey sources
tell me I know you're connected with
Brady I understand that but you said
sources then I would I
if you look at some of the other tweets
that have to do with Brady oh my god I'm
hearing about or is you know what I'm
feeling or getting the feet like I don't
know what is real and what is just
understand that and that's the landscape
that's the tough part like that's what I
think we're all sort of working against
and around and trying to figure out but
all I know to do is just hold to it
eventually I built the reputation where
Dan Patrick for instance these are like
who the hell is Jeff Darlington and I'm
not believing in Salonika successes
what's a fair chapter has been
computation I get that and I'm not you
know okay hey by the way god I hope I'm
right if you hit the lottery here this
this will be great because then I'll be
saying you know I trust what Darlington
says I'm not sure about chef teah and
Glaser
I mean honestly like that's I'm sitting
here and I'm again talking to the people
close to Tom yesterday I'm like we're
all sitting but you know like what if he
goes into Bello Jack's office okay are
you taking Paulie up on his bed for
dan-levitan also bet me that if if Tom
goes back to New England that he because
I said I would be I would be stunned
yeah taze me that he can take a Taser to
me and stun me
I like that the thousand dollars that
sounds way better to me so you'll take
pulling up on the bed well I'm not going
to
I love degenerate gamblers like Polly
but I don't think that I'm a lot I don't
think I'm allowed to do that but I will
certainly be happy to Paulie you want to
modify this bed with Jeff Darlington
journalist first off Jeff degenerate
gamblers are the ones that lose not the
ones that win secondly yeah we don't
want to get you in trouble at the
mothership so we can alter the bet my
bet ultimate would be something
involving your hair you have great moss
oh
crew-cut yeah that's just that's just
too far appalling I sound insane I'm
they're with you Jeff I mean I would
sorry I take it just because I'm
confident yeah I guess my money over
mouth is it just feels like that's a
little harsh
god forbid how about five hundred each
for charity yes I'll do that
Paulie you got your charity yeah it's a
really good one it's my charities a real
nice one it's called the Paul paps log
cabin fund okay it's a really small I'm
sure Jeff would be happy to contribute
to that
okay so Wow Jeff with a shot nice know
you'll do the charity angle I'll throw
this disclaimer they'll make sure I'm
allowed to do that but I'm happy to yeah
you know what how about this the V
Foundation is perfect there you go
so either way Paulie donates five
hundred or you donate five hundred Jeff
yeah love that love that but thank you
for having me god damn yes well III I
hate the whole Tom Brady situation
because I think no but you know what
yeah but do you know what drives me
crazy about this is you might be correct
with this and other people will steal
they'll borrow from you and then they'll
go hey I'm hearing it's like when I came
out with Philip Rivers to the Colts and
I that was at the Super Bowl the number
of people said you know I'm see Philip
Rivers to the Colts and I went okay I'm
reporting from a source I actually said
I had a source Jeff that just saw the
leading candidate for Brady is who if
it's not the Patriots right there I mean
that's like I'm going to sound really
lame there is not like look I'll say
four teams right now that are interested
in Tom the Titans the Raiders the
Chargers
okay I'm also going to tell you that
yesterday you were mocking the idea of
the Bucs
yeah don't discount okay okay so
breaking news no Jeff Darlington yeah
but you didn't say sources yesterday all
right so Tom Brady to the Buccaneers
Jameis goes to New England
okay the one I really dispelled was Tom
to the Cowboys yeah I mean they got to
get it done with that right I
Mississippi thing she's not going to the
Cowboys they can't get it done with that
yes he's their future the only thing
that I do find interesting about this
whole crazy thing is that it that like
there's very few to like yeah there's a
wide net right now like it really is
honestly such at such a when it comes to
like the team's there are a bunch of
teams that are interested in him yeah
and she's honestly not discounting them
but to your point the Cowboys feels like
that feels like a little bit pie in the
sky
it's called trolling as what it is Jeff
yes I'm not I'm not
Darlington says the Buccaneers for Tom
Brady don't rule it out you're the jet
you're the Jay Glazer with better hair
tolerance hey great appearance and and
from now on if I don't hear you say
sources I'm going to assume that you
mean sources Jeff that's Jeff Darlington
NFL reporter for ESPN he was listening
to the show I didn't know he'd listen to
the show I probably wouldn't have said
all those mean things about him